[Music]
the goal
is to disappear behind our masks as
pleasant interchangeable helpers
it's tropical kabuki hello happy to be
here we're on our honeymoon
you're such a valued guest welcome to
the white lotus
are they bigger nicole they're [ __ ]
huge i haven't seen them in a while
it's cancer slow balls say biopsy or
balls dad
not yet surprised
am i interrupting i know it's only your
honeymoon
oh my god look at her face rachel you
were such a beautiful bride
but also very pale but now you have a
little more color and it looks great
thanks you are so talented
do you really know what you're doing
[Music]
you think you could have dinner with me
at the hotel tonight um
i get off at seven yeah that's good i
mean like a couple minutes after seven
at the
at the restaurant sounds great
in a young man this time right now can't
be easy
why because we can't harass girls
anymore no
well he thinks i'm an [ __ ]
were you an [ __ ] i guess i'm just
wondering what um you might be able to
do for us to make us feel better
no i was actually trying to not be an
[ __ ]
that you failed
[Music]
where were you i just walked around
[Music]
please enjoy
belinda is the best dude i'll make an
appointment if she's not booked with me
sometimes just watching them eat every
night makes me want to
gouge my eyes out
what i want is to speak to your boss
[ __ ] this place i don't think it's the
most romantic hotel in hawaii do you
it's perfectly fine but are you finding
it very romantic okay
[Music]
you